president biden not crazy is taking a
big new step to get more americans
vaccinated
to reach a highly publicized goal that
may now be in doubt
about 63 percent of american adults have
had at least
one covet shot more than 162 million of
that
more than 162 million of us that number
needs to grow by more than
18 million to reach mr biden's goal of
70 percent by the 4th of july
the president has declared june a
national month of action and is
promoting a
blitz of new giveaways to try to reverse
falling vaccination rates ouija zhang is
at the white house wija what's he
offering folks
good morning anthony all kinds of things
you know some states have already been
using giveaways as incentives to
encourage people to get vaccinated
and now the white house is partnering
with several businesses to try to boost
the vaccine rate
that means people who get their shots at
cvs have a chance at winning
super bowl tickets or free cruises fans
who get vaccinated at major league
baseball games could also get free
tickets
and yes guys free booze for adults 21
and over
from anheuser-busch with the president
selling the slogan
get a shot and have a beer he also
announced that four of the country's
biggest day care providers will offer
free drop in child care
for parents getting their shots this
all-out effort comes
amid concerns that the average daily
vaccination rate
is just over 1 million doses a day
down from its mid-april peak of an
average of around 3.3 million doses
a vaccination campaign could be
especially important in the south
which is lag behind in getting shots in
arms for example
six southern states have less than one
third of their population fully
vaccinated
president biden the first lady and vice
president harris are expected to hit the
road for the final push
and what they are calling the we can do
it tour which will focus
on education and outreach gail
we should thank you